>> CHUCK AND I ARE NOT IN A
NEGOTIATION.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO
$5 MILLION FOR THE WALL.
>> Laura: NOW THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE WON CONTROL OF THE HOUSE,
DID PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LAST BEST
CHANCE OF GETTING THE WALL
ALREADY SLIPPED THROUGH HIS
FINGERS?
EARLIER THIS YEAR HE CAME OUT
SWINGING AGAINST A BIPARTISAN
IMMIGRATION BILL THAT WOULD HAVE
FUNDED THE WALL AND PROVIDED A
PATH TO CITIZENSHIP FOR DOC
RECIPIENTS CALLING IT A
CATASTROPHE AND A GIANT
AMNESTY.
THE BILL FAILED AND THE WALL,
WELL, STILL NOT BILLED.
JOINING ME NOW I STEPHEN MILLER,
SENIOR POLICY ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DOES THE PRESIDENT FEEL LIKE
THIS IS LIKE THE SAND IN THE
HOURGLASS THAT SLIPPED THROUGH
THAT LITTLE TINY HOLE?
>> NOT AT ALL.
THE BILL YOU MENTIONED WOULD
HAVE BEEN A TOTAL CATASTROPHE
AND GUIDED INTERIOR ENFORCEMENT
PERMANENTLY FOREVER.
WE'VE ALREADY BUILT OVER
100 MILES OF THE WALL.
THIS STAND WE ARE TAKING RIGHT
NOW WITH THE ENTIRE NATION
WATCHING AND FRANKLY THE WHOLE
WORLD WATCHING IS A STAND WE
THINK WE ARE GOING TO WIN.
>> Laura: THE FACT-CHECKER SAY
YOUR BORDER WILL CLAIM THE
PRESIDENT SAID A LOT OF IT IS
ALREADY BUILT WAS NOT TRUE.
>> THE FACT-CHECKERS TYPICALLY
ARE WRONG ABOUT THESE THINGS AND
THEY CERTAINLY ARE IN THIS CASE.
>> Laura: IS THERE A NEW WALL?
SUPER-DUPER NEW WALL?
>> A BEAUTIFUL 30-FOOT ROCK
SOLID WALL.
>> Laura: IS IT UP HIGH?
>> 30 FEET TALL.
UNLIKE THE OLD ONE, YOU HAVE IN
THE SAN DIEGO AREA AND MANY
OTHER AREAS.
THE 30-FOOT BARRIER.
>> Laura: I'M GOING THERE.
I'M GOING TO GO DO A SHOW FROM
THE WALL.
>> YOU SEE THE OLD SHORTER
BARRIER THAT PREDATED THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU SEE PEOPLE CLIMBING OVER IT
AND THROWING HUMAN BEINGS OVER
IT.
YOU NEED THE 30-FOOT HEIGHT.
I WANT TO GET TO THE REAL ISSUE
AT HAND.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE FIGHTING FOR
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
DONALD TRUMP IS FIGHTING FOR
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
THAT'S WHAT THIS WHOLE THING IS
ABOUT.
YOU HAVE COVERED THIS BETTER
THAN PROBABLY ANYBODY FOR YEARS.
YOU UNDERSTAND IT'S ABOUT
SOVEREIGNTY.
IT'S ABOUT WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN.
IT'S ABOUT SAFE COMMUNITIES.
IT'S ABOUT WAGES, LIVING
CONDITIONS, QUALITY OF LIFE.
THIS IS THE BATTLE RIGHT NOW
RIGHT BEFORE OUR VERY EYES.
WE ARE GOING TO WIN BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT BACKING
DOWN.
>> Laura: JEFF FLAKE OUTGOING.
YOU'D BE SURPRISED TO KNOW HE
DISAGREES WITH YOU.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THE NOTION THAT DEMOCRATS
HAVE PREVENTED ANY FIX, THE LAST
REAL VOTE WE HAD ON SUBSTANTIAL
IMMIGRATION REFORM WAS THE
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT WE DID IN
2013.
EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THE SENATE
VOTED FOR THAT BILL.
THIS NOTION THAT IT'S THE
DEMOCRATS FAULT IS JUST WRONG.
>> Laura: IS THAT TRUE?
DO REPUBLICANS DESERVE SOME
BLAME?
WE HAVE A LOT OF CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE TYPE REPUBLICANS.
I JUST HAD A GUY FROM CATO ON.
NICE GUY BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO
BORDER.
THEY WANT CHEAP LABOR AND A GLUT
OF WORKERS.
NOW WE HAVE A DEARTH OF
BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS.
>> ZOOM OUT.
LAST FEW DECADES OF AMERICAN
HISTORY, THERE IS NO QUESTION
THAT BOTH PARTIES IN AMERICA
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO UNWISE
FOREIGN POLICY, UNWISE TRADE
POLICY AND UNWISE IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
DONALD TRUMP CAME INTO OFFICE
AND HAS TURNED IT ALL AROUND.
GETTING TOUGH ON CHINA ON TRADE.
RENEGOTIATING NAFTA.
CRACKING DOWN ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
DEALING WITH UNSKILLED LOW-WAGE
MIGRATION.
REORIENTING OUR FOREIGN POLICY.
ALL THESE ISSUES, LAURA, THAT
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED WORKING
PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY FOR
DECADES, HE'S TURNED THEM
AROUND.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY OF TODAY, NOT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF THE
YEARS PASS, NOT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY OF BILL CLINTON AND THEY
'90s.
>> Laura: WE KNOW THAT.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO GET THE
WALL BUILT?
HE CAMPAIGNED ON THE WALL.
MEXICO IS GOING TO PAY FOR.
MEXICO IS NOT GOING TO PAY FOR
IT AND LET YOU TELL ME SOMETHING
TO FIGHT I DON'T KNOW.
>> THE SAVINGS FROM TRADE ALONE
WILL FUND IT.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE BRINGING UP
FUNDING ISSUES.
JUST THE COST OF HEROIN IN OUR
COUNTRY IS $230 BILLION.
JUST THE COST OF PUBLIC BENEFITS
FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS EVERY
YEAR IS OVER 100 --
>> Laura: WE DID IT,
18 BILLION JUST FOR HEALTH CARE
A YEAR FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THAT'S PAYING FOR MOST OF THE
WALL RIGHT THERE.
THIS IS WHAT CHUCK SCHUMER SAID
ABOUT THE NAFTA PAYMENT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THE PRESIDENT REPEATEDLY
PROMISED THAT MEXICO WOULD PAY
FOR HIS UNNECESSARY AND
INEFFECTIVE BORDER WALL.
WELL, MR. PRESIDENT, IF YOU SAY
MEXICO IS GOING TO PAY FOR THE
WALL THROUGH NAFTA WHICH IT
CERTAINLY WON'T, THEN I GUESS WE
DON'T HAVE TO.
>> Laura: WELL.
>> FIRST OF ALL, CHUCK SCHUMER
WAS FOR THE WALL WHEN HE VOTED
FOR THE SECURE FENCE ACT IN
2,006.
NOW THAT THE DEMOCRAT PARTY HAS
BEEN COME THE PARTY OF NO
BORDERS AND DONALD TRUMP IS
PRESENT, HE'S AGAINST IT.
IF CHUCK SCHUMER WANTS TO PASS
LEGISLATION SAYING WE CAN SPEND
OUR TRADE SAVINGS ON BORDER
SECURITY, THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
IN THE MEANTIME THE SAVINGS FOR
THE TRADE DEAL WILL OFFSET THE
COST OF THE WALL AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THAN ALL OF THAT,
THERE WALL IS GOING TO SAVE
AMERICAN LIVES.
IT'S GOING TO SAVE AMERICAN
JOBS.
ENDS GOING TO SAVE IN THE
LONG-TERM HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
>> Laura: YOU NEED THE ASYLUM
REFORM.
YOU'VE WRITTEN ABOUT THIS.
I'VE CERTAINLY WRITTEN ABOUT IT.
WITHOUT THAT REFORM, FOR PEOPLE
WHO CROSS THE BORDER WITH A
CHILD OR SOMEONE WHO THEY SAY AS
A CHILD AND IS NOT A CHILD, THEY
ARE STILL BEING RELEASED, ARE
THEY NOT?
YOU CAN'T DETAIN AND HOW IS
EVERYBODY.
THERE ARE TOO MANY PEOPLE.
THEY ARE EFFECTIVELY BEING
RELEASED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE REFORMS IN PLACE.
HOW DO WE DO THAT WITH A
DEMOCRAT HOUSE QUESTION MARKS TO
GO THIS IS GOING TO BE ONE OF
THE DEFINING ISSUES OF THE NEXT
TWO YEARS HEADING INTO 2020.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOLLOWS THE
PATH OF OPEN BORDERS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS GOING TO
ENGAGE IN SELF IMMOLATION.
IF DONALD TRUMP IS FIGHTING FOR
WORKING PEOPLE AND HE'S FIGHTING
TO RESTORE THE BORDERS AROUND
THIS COUNTRY THAT ARE THE
ESSENTIAL INGREDIENT FOR
NATIONAL SOVEREIGNTY AND
NATIONAL SUCCESS IN A WAY THAT
NOBODY HAS WHO HAS HELD THAT
OFFICE NOT ONLY IN MY LIFETIME
BUT FRANKLY IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Laura: DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
CAN GO OUT IN PUBLIC AND
RESTAURANTS IN WASHINGTON AND DO
YOU?
>> I HAVE NO CONCERNS.
>> Laura: SO YOU EAT.
YOU'RE FINE.
WHAT WAS THAT BROADWAY SHOW
GOING ON OUTSIDE YOUR HOUSE
YESTERDAY?
DO WE HAVE A VIDEO?
RAYMOND SAID -- WHO IS IT?
I DON'T KNOW.
WHO IS PAYING THESE PEOPLE
QUESTION MONKEY WEREN'T EVEN
THERE.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE WALLS, DO YOU
COME OUTSIDE YOUR HOUSE?
>> IRONICALLY THEY WOULD HAVE
BETTER CHANCE GETTING JOBS IF WE
CAN INITIATE SUMMARY FORMS.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE CHIEF
OF STAFF SEARCH.
I HEARD AND ENDLESSLY IT'S A
NIGHTMARE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS SPIRIT IS BAD.
EVERYONE IS DEPRESSED.
THEY SAID IT A YEAR AGO AND
ALMOST TWO YEARS AGO.
NUMBER ONE, WHAT'S THE SPIRIT IN
NUMBER ONE, WHAT'S THE SPIRIT II
THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> THE SPIRIT IS WONDERFUL.
NOT ONLY IS A WONDERFUL SPIRIT
OF SACRED CHRISTMAS SEASON BUT
ALSO THE WONDERFUL SPIRIT OF
GETTING TO WORK FOR A LEADER WHO
IS FIGHTING FOR EVERY DAY
ORDINARY CITIZENS, JUST REGULAR
FAMILIES.
IN EVERY PART OF THE COUNTRY.
YOU DID YOUR SEGMENT ON
OPPORTUNITY ZONES.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN,
HISPANIC-AMERICAN.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE POWERFUL
LOBBIES OR SPECIAL INTEREST,
DON'T HAVE CORPORATE COMPANIES
AND LARGE MULTINATIONAL
BUSINESSES.
EVERY DAY PEOPLE.
THEY NOW HAVE A CHAMPION IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
GETTING TO WORK FOR A PRESIDENT
WHO FIGHTS EVERY DAY FOR JUST
NORMAL EVERYDAY CITIZENS IS A
PRIVILEGE BEYOND WORDS.
ALL THE PEOPLE I WORK WITH FEEL
THE SAME WAY.
>> Laura: THEY ARE GOING TO
FOCUS ON THE 7-YEAR-OLD WHO,
THIS HORRIFIC STORY, A MIGRANT
GIRL WHO DIED FROM DEHYDRATION
AFTER BEING BROUGHT INTO THE
COUNTRY OR A PARENT BROUGHT HER.
SHE DIED.
THE LEFT WILL FOCUS ON THAT.
THAT IT'S REPUBLICANS' FAULT FOR
BELIEVING IN A BORDER.
THEY PLAYED THE EMOTION GAME AND
OFTENTIMES WE PLAY THE FACT
GAME.
FACTS ARE VERY ANTISEPTIC.
EMOTIONAL STORIES SELL THE CASE.
>> IMMIGRATION IS AN EMOTIONAL
ISSUE.
IT OUGHT TO BE AN EMOTIONAL
ISSUE BECAUSE IT AFFECTS
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
IF YOU WANT TO STOP THE HORRORS
ON THE NORTHWARD TRACK, THE RAPE
AND ABUSE AND DEATH THAT OCCURS,
THEN FOR THE LOVE OF GOD, FUND
THE BORDER WALL.
>> Laura: CHRIS CHRISTIE CHIEF
OF STAFF?
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE HEARING
TONIGHT?
ANY COMMENTS.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE ANY
NEWS ON THE CHIEF OF STAFF
ANNOUNCEMENT.
HOWEVER THE PRESIDENT USES IS